[موسيقى]
الليله
ورايحه لبيتي
الاغنيه التراثيه العراقيه تسبق الكتب
دائما في معارضها السنويه في معرض العراق
الدولي للكتاب يتفاعل الجمهور مع ما تقدمه
هذه الفرقه من اغنيه يعتبرها العراقيون
جزءا من ثقافتهم في امسيه ستتكرر طيله
ايام المعرض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العراق الدولي للكتاب موعده الثابت سنويا
11 يوما من شهر كانون الاول ديسمبر كما
يحافظ المعرض على تقليده السنوي في تكريمه
تحت الشخصيات العراقيه في كل دوره منه
المعرض يشمل عده فعاليات مو بس الكتب
في الرسم قسم المسرح قسم الفنون المشاركه
العربيه
مميزه هذا العام المشاركه بالنسبه الى
العربيه تقتصر على عرض الكتبهما احنا
دايما موجودين في معرض العراق الدولي
همم للكتاب دار التوفيق للتراث بتكون
بخدمه للقارئ في
اول طالب العلم في العراق هذه الكتب بعضها
مكرر في الجامعات في العراق
[موسيقى]
مع اتحاد الكتاب في العراق
افتتاح رئيس الحكومه العراقيه الحالي محمد
السوداني لهذه الدوره كان احد اسباب
مقاطعه جمهور معارضيه للمعارض ولا سيما من
التيار الصدري ومع ذلك قدم المعرفه عنوان
من اكثر من 350 دينار نشرنا من 20 دوله